We all want to be normal but our picture
of what is normal is in fact really
unhelpful. So many of the things were
told that are weird are in fact
completely average and widespread. For
example, if you fear you married the wrong
person; get sick with envy when a friend
succeeds; fantasize about your wife's
sister; want to cry when anyone
criticizes you; dislike the way you look;
panic at the thought of going to a party;
worry a great deal about farting in public
feel you might vomit during a meeting
out of fear have ever had a lustful
thought about a member of your own
family
bump your head while trying to get into
a taxi are turned on by some pretty
strange people are stories in the news
frequently visit adult websites regard
yourself as a fraud worry about not
making it to the bathroom in time
walk into doors lamppost, rearview
mirrors, callers or that other people can
see your private parts; still think about
a relationship that ended badly
eleven years ago
Then you can quietly congratulate
yourself you are deeply normal
We suffer so much and so unnecessarily because our
picture of what is normal isn't true to
how most of us actually are
We get
disgusted and ashamed of ourselves for
no reason
There's nothing strange about
being compulsive, manic, anxious, sexual or
even more mad
Being odd is normal
and that's ok
It has become hard to say anything; especially on
social media that won't upset someone
somewhere has a myriad of